So Hank, the other day, I went to my barber and I was like, "Can I get a haircut?"
and she said, "I'll cut your hair, but I'm not gonna cut your puff."
[Intro music]
Now Hank, you and the nerdfighters may have been wondering why
I haven't made a video in almost a week and a half. It's not because I got this hilariously bad haircut;
I've never been embarrassed to share my hilariously bad haircuts.
And it's not because I've been dealing with this gigantic pile of mulch either,
although when that pile of mulch initially arrived at my house,
it was larger than my apartment in New York.
Nor is it because I've been fondling all the awesome stuff
that nerdfighters brought us in Grand Rapids, Michigan,
like this ceramic cup that says DFTBA on it
and this book which is called "Scruffy Teddy Likes To Play In Your Pants"
Scruffy Teddy, you need a bath
because you are a dirty boy.
No Hank, the reason I haven't made a video in almost a week and a half
is that the Yeti and I have made an extraordinary acquisition
that is unbelievably time-consuming.
Hank, without further ado,
allow me to introduce you #
to Bubbles the Nerdfighting Puppy.
Okay, we don't actually call him Bubbles the Nerdfighting Puppy,
I wanted to but the Yeti was like,
"It's gonna be weird when
we try to explain to people that he's a boy
but his name is Bubbles the Nerdfighting Puppy."
And then you know, everyone's gonna be like,
"Are nerdfighters for nerds or against nerds?"
which is a stupid question, I mean, look at my glasses.
No, Hank, we call this adorable ball of fluff,
Willy.
Okay I'm just gonna keep talking,
while he does cute stuff.
Willy's full name is
Fireball Wilson Roberts,
which is a reference to the first sentence of James Crumley's classic novel, the Last Good Kiss:
"When I finally caught up with Abraham Trahearne,
he was drinking beer with
an alcoholic bulldog named Fireball Roberts
in a ramshackle joint, just outside of Sonoma, California,
drinking the heart right out of a fine spring afternoon.
Now Hank, Willy's a pretty adorable puppy.
Particularly when you're appreciating him through the medium of video,
so that you're not aware of the fact
that he always smells a little bit like his own pee.
And I like Willy very much,
but I have a message for all of the nerdfighters out there,
who might be considering getting a puppy:
Oh.
My.
God.
It is so
hard.
I mean Willy pretty much requires constant attention
and when he doesn't get our full attention,
he makes this noise that's like
all the kittens in the world
have united with all the birds in the world
and they've gone to war with monkeys and
puppy-sized elephants.
It's like Buddhist monks throat-singing;
he's doing seven notes at once.
Also his favorite thing in the world to do
is to go outside and make you think he's gonna pee
and you think he's gonna pee and you think he's gonna pee
and then uh-
ohhhh
he just lay down.
So sometimes I get pretty frustrated with him
but then he'll be sitting across the room from me and, oh-
Oh he'll do that thing where he turns his head to the side,
it's so cute!
And then I forgive him for everything.
So Hank, that's Willy.
I apologize for not making more videos more often,
but as I'm sure you can tell,
he's a bundle of joy
and a bundle of work.
However, I am going to make up for my lack of videos last week,
by doing a punishment this week.
That punishment?
I'm gonna do a video every day this week.
This is going to include two Question Tuesdays,
so nerdfighters, please leave your questions and comments.
Also with every video of this week,
I'm going to give away one copy of Paper Towns to a random commenter
and yes, that includes this video.
For the purposes of this punishment,
the week is going to be Sunday, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday and Thursday;
I'm taking Friday off
because, as everyone knows,
Friday night is the Sabbath if you're Jewish,
which I'm not but I'm taking it off.
Hank, you'll see-
Willy.
Willy. C'mon.
Cooperate.
Co- no licking.
No- Hank,
you'll see-
Hank, you'll see me tomorrow.
Katherine, happy birthday.
Willy say, "Happy birthday, Katherine."
Say- oh! He's waving!
Happy birthday, Katherine!
Oh yeah, did I mention that he's a talking dog?